Hi, this is Anne from Conner's Clinic, and in this video we're going to walk you through how to use the computer.
So when you get your box that contains all the right equipment, the computer is one piece that equipment.
So the computer is a laptop, it might not look exactly like the one that I have in front of me, but it's going to look similar and the functionality is going to be the same.
So there's obviously going to be a charging cord for the computer.
So you might have the cord on right side or the left side, so you'll just have to look to see where the power plug in, the spot is.
And then you're going to want to have the cord plugged into your search protector.
So let's just get that plugged in.
Alright, so once it is the computer is plugged in, you're just going to open up the computer, and then you're going to want to power the computer on.
So the power button on this version of the laptop is right here.
Sometimes it might be in the upper right side, sometimes it might be on either side here.
So you'll have to locate the power button, and then you just hold it down for a couple seconds, and the computer screen should turn on like that.
Now this is the track pad.
So in order to move the cursor, you're just dragging your finger along this track pad, and you can see that the cursor is moving.
So if you just tap anywhere on the screen, it should bring you to this sign-in page, so you just tap on this sign-in button.
So on this track pad, you can just tap on the middle, or we have these right and left click buttons here.
Not all of the track pads are going to have these buttons, distinguished buttons, but the track pad, you can just click on, and that will work as a clicker.
So one thing you'll want to note about the track pad is right-clicking and left-clicking.
So you can see on this track pad, there's distinct buttons to indicate a right-click or a left-click.
Not all of the track pads have those. Sometimes you'll just have to right-click in the lower right corner of the track pad, but on this computer we have these distinct buttons.
So you have to select whatever the left-click button is to select something.
So right now I have this hovered over John Doe, and I'm left-clicking on this left button.
And you can see it puts a little check mark there, or sometimes it's just going to highlight what you've selected.
You can use the left button's upper or lower on this track pad.
The right button is to bring up another menu option where you can copy and paste.
So I just right-clicked there, and we have this. So you can copy.
So in the event that you are getting new files that you want to upload to your true rife frequencies, the program, we will give you instructions, but this is just an example of why you would be right-clicking.
You're right-clicking to copy, and then you select with the left side.
So you've right-click to open up this menu, and then you want to select copy.
And so you left-click on copy, and then you would hit on the documents tab.
You're left-clicking to select this, and now you are going to left-click again on this.
Yeah, we're highlighting this, and we're going to right-click to bring up that menu again, and then we want to paste.
So we're hovering over paste, and then we're going to left-click to select it, and that pastes the new programs into the true rife folder.
Now, if your programs are named the same thing, it may ask you if you want the new files to overwrite the old files.
That is fine. Sometimes we're naming the new programs something different, so it's not going to erase the old files.
It's just going to make a new file with the new programs.
And so that's an example of when you would want to use a right-click to copy your paste.
Left-click is always to select whatever you're hovering over what you have highlighted.
So I hope that helps clarify the trackpad for people.
Another thing that you can do if the trackpad is confusing, and you're used to using a mouse, you can plug a mouse into the USB drive here, and then you can use the mouse to navigate the computer's phrase.
You don't have to use the trackpad, so that's an option as well.
The computer has the videos, so these are the instructional videos that will walk you through setting up the rife machine, setting up the ion pro wave.
There's also some educational videos on there that you'll want to watch, and then this over here is the true rife icon.
So that's what you're going to be clicking into in order to get your programs loaded and running.
So when you receive your computer, we are putting it in airplane mode. You can see there's a little icon down here that looks like an airplane.
And so you don't need internet to run any of your rife programs.
You don't need to do any software updates or virus install any virus protection.
Really, you're just using this computer to run your rife programs and you don't need internet.
So you can keep it on airplane mode. The only time you would need to connect to wi-fi would be a couple, maybe three times a year, if you want to update the general programs that are provided by true rife.
So you would connect to your wi-fi by clicking on that little airplane, and then there's this wi-fi button here.
You would just click on that and then turn or put your password into connect to your wi-fi.
And then we'll show you how to update the rife frequencies in the rife training video, but that's how you connect to wi-fi.
Back to the power button. So it is good, maybe one time a week, if you can pick a day of the week, maybe Sunday morning, you're going to wake up and you're going to completely power down the computer.
It just helps to kind of reset things and prevent any miscommunications between the rife and the computer if you're completely powering the computer down every so often.
So pick a day of the week where it's convenient and then power down the rife machine. You can do that by holding this power button down.
If you just tap it, it's going to put it into sleep mode and you certainly can obviously close the computer.
But we want to do a full power down of the computer so it resets. So I'm just waking it back up, was sleeping.
Now if I want to do a complete power down, I can either put my cursor over here and highlight over the little windows icon and click on it.
Then hit this little circle with a line through it, button that says power. So I can hit that and I can do a shutdown.
And that will power down the computer or you can just hold this power button down for a good, you know, 15 seconds until power is completely down.
Then you can give it 30 seconds and then start it back up again and that should reset the computer.
One thing you'll notice on the side of your computer here is these USB ports. So you have one, typically they'll have one on either side.
So there's one on this side, there's also one on the other side. That you'll be using a USB cord to run from your computer to the rife machine.
And then also if there's any time where you're receiving a flash drive from us with updated programs or changes to your programs,
the flash drive will plug into this USB port and there'll be instructions provided on how to install those new programs.